des nouvelles de l'attentât qui s'est
produit il y à un peu plus d'une demi
heure une commère rue copernic dans le
16e arrondissement une synagogue
je viens de recevoir les premières
images et le reportage de xavier robert
tout le regardons tout de suite
l'explosion a eu lieu aux alentours de
18h45 à la synagogue israélite libérale
de la rue copernic au numéro 24 de cette
rue copernic
pas très loin de la place victor hugo
dans le 8e arrondissement
les secours sont en train d'arriver il
est 19h10 en ce moment le ministre de
l'intérieur christian bonnet vient
d'arriver également sur les lieux de cet
attentant attentats encore entre
guillemets puisqu'il s'agit d'une
explosion
je vous propose d'écouter l'interview du
rabbin williams un anglais qui étaient à
l'intérieur de la synagogue
quand l'explosion s'est produite écoutez
le une voiture piégée et une bombe qui
était d'exposer avec une violence inouïe
il y avait trois ou quatre cents
personnes à la synagogue et j'ai vu dans
la rue au moins deux personnes mortes
moins une personne absolument dé
plusieurs personnes grièvement blessées
vous êtes sûr de ce premier bilan
maintenant je vis une personne morte et
plusieurs personnes amassées d'un gang
blessés quelles explications déjà dévié
de redonner cette évidence cher monsieur
cette bombe plantée par nos amis et les
antisémites et nazis de france que
peut-on dire sauf une seule chose est un
message pour eux et pour tout le peuple
français et pour tous les juifs de
france nous n'avons pas peur
et demain matin nous allons prier dans
cette synagogue de la rue copernic
demain matin et la semaine prochaine et
toute la semaine et pour toujours
nous n'avons pas peur